begin this uh Wednesday night with the
Fox News Alert Joe Biden has been caught
mishandling classified documents yet
again for the second time this week we
are now learning that secret material
from the Obama Administration turned up
in another private unsecured office
accessed by Joe Biden during his time as
a private citizen I think it's time for
Mar-A-Lago style raid to happen at Joe
Biden's private residences where he's
building a wall by the way or maybe
someone in Joe's Inner Circle think
about this why is this happening twice
in a week could this be the result maybe
someone doesn't want Joe to run for
reelection well we absolutely don't know
that to be a fact it's certainly
suspicious in terms of timing but what's
good for the goose is certainly good for
the gander right Merrick Garland right
Chris Ray they are the ones that
personally approved of the raid at
Mar-A-Lago and former president Trump's
home this is why Jim Jordan's
investigation on the Judiciary Committee
into whether or not our FBI is
politicized and doj weaponized is so
important it is so obvious that many
America's powerful bureaucrats they are
using their powerful positions to impugn
Republicans and protect Democrats now if
that's not the case that Biden's home in
Delaware would have already been raided
by the feds a criminal investigation
would already be underway after all even
Joe Biden agrees that mishandling
classified material is an egregious
offense take a look at his own words
when you saw the photograph of the top
secret documents laid out on the floor
at Mar-A-Lago what did you think to
yourself looking at that image
how that could possibly happen how one
anyone could be that irresponsible
and I thought what data was in there
that may compromise sources and methods
by that I mean names of people who
helped or et cetera and it just uh
totally irresponsible
wow how Joe how could that happen how
could you be so irresponsible anyway
today our very own peter Ducey asked the
White House Press Secretary if the
president still believes that it's
irresponsible to mishandle classified
material needless to say Kareem
Jean-Pierre was not able to answer the
question she had a tough day oh well
take a look
on these documents how could anyone be
that irresponsible
isn't that what this President says
about mishandling classified documents
the president spoke to this personally
he spoke to this personally he again he
believes that classified documents and
information should be taken seriously he
takes them seriously and he was
surprised to learn by any any records
had been I disagree I disagree here's
what happened here's what happened once
his parents Department well let me let
me explain to you the process here's
what happened when his lawyers found out
that the documents were there they
immediately turned them over to their
archives but they immediately turned
them over to the icons I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna go into specifics but I'm
going I what I am reiterating to you is
what you heard from the president
yourself Peter which is how he saw the
process and how he respects and truly uh
uh respects and takes this very
seriously
Checkmate Peter Ducey how can that
happen how can one be so irresponsible
uh so right was supposed to believe
Biden takes it so seriously that he left
top secret classified material behind
for the taking here there everywhere for
years but according to Democrats the mob
and the media Joe Biden is allowed to
mishandle top secret classified material
now when Donald Trump is accused of
mishandling documents then it becomes a
national security crisis but if Joe
Biden does it no big deal for example
look at the Washington Post their fact
Checker so-called fact Checker who's
going to fact check the fact Checker uh
anyway Glenn Kessler bent over backwards
trying to explain how the two cases are
totally different he may need to fact
check himself did the Associated Press
the New York Times They did the same
thing they're running cover for Joe
Biden they're an extension of Kareen
Jean-Pierre in the White House Press
office and by the way fake news CNN with
an article titled are clear distinctions
between Trump and Biden's two cases
according to them quote the new
controversy so far appear appears to be
on a smaller scale
it's now getting bigger now of course
there are differences between the two
cases well first of all Donald Trump was
President Donald Trump had the power to
declassify anything when these documents
were transported to Mar-A-Lago by the
way there's no set process for
declassification Joe Biden as vice
president did not have that power second
Donald Trump's documents was stored in a
room that had been examined specifically
by the FBI they asked Donald Trump and
his team to secure that room with a
padlock at their request he did so and
by the way they had full-time security
cameras on that door at all times anyway
Biden's documents were found now in
multiple locations including one
facility bought and paid for by the
Communist Party of China or whoever you
want to classify however you want to
classify the 54 plus million dollars
China donated and third the documents at
Mar-A-Lago they were recovered by force
less than two years after Donald Trump
left off office by contrast Biden left
top secret documents dangling in the
wind for over six years according to the
intellectual heavyweights in the
Democratic party Biden is good Trump is
bad take a look
and the intelligence Community needs to
do its risk and damage assessment about
how Donald Trump's very Reckless
handling of these documents might have
harmed our national security this is
going to be politicized I imagine it is
already been politicized by those on the
right and the former president if the
Trump people represented that they
provided all the classified or national
security information and didn't that's a
serious problem but we see no evidence
of deliberate intent or obstruction of
justice as we see in the face of Donald
Trump this was not a mistake that these
documents landed you know at Mar-A-Lago
this is what he intended and it also by
the way shows that they really want to
get these documents back and every
second that they're at this beach house
in the possession of Donald Trump is a
risk to our national security well we
all know that Trump is a liar and a
thief you know
so it's not that big a jump to say that
he obstructed and he lied we don't think
that Biden is a liar and a thief so we
give him the benefit of the doubt so the
blatant bias the blatant hypocrisy is
probably Now worse than ever but not
just from Democrats and the media mob
again America's once trusted
institutions they're worse just look at
the two-tier justice system we have and
hand it down from the FBI in the doj
they treated Capital rioters like
terrorists they gave Portland rioters
who have 574 riots in the summer of 2020
574. dozens of dead Americans billions
in property damage and thousands of
injured cops they didn't have any
hearings on that they investigated
Donald Trump over the Russia hoax even
offered an ex-foreign spy a million
dollars to make it true uh but guess
what they won't dare touch the bribery
corruption allegations against the Biden
family Syndicate now they conducted
early morning raids in tactical gear
against numerous Trump Associates even
Trump himself and yet not even Hunter
who recovered his you know we've
recorded his many crimes against any of
the same treatment they give Hillary
Clinton she was probably the worst of
everybody a free pass she mishandled top
secret classified documents she's the
one that deleted 33 000 emails remember
with bleach bid uh to take cover uh in
terms of her record and background we
have no idea where the 33 000 emails
have said or where they are the media
mob they don't care democracy dies in
darkness doesn't it or is that just a
cute motto over at the Washington Post
and not really a principled belief that
so-called journalists at nearly every
paper nearly every news Outlet are only
interested in protecting Democrats and
our federal government instead of
actually holding them accountable hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else